as temperatures rise for summer
electricity prices usually follow that
same upward trend but this year rates
could be especially high there's higher
air conditioning use during the summer
which means people are using more
electricity and when there's you know
higher demand it can result in higher
prices an estimate from eversource
energy new england's largest energy
delivery company said the average
residential customer could see bills
increase by as much as 25
through the end of june so how did the
cost of electricity get so high and what
can households do to manage the price
height come summer time it's a story
involving geopolitics severe weather
events and inflation and at the center
of it lies one resource
natural gas it's very important it's the
largest
source of generation at this time
renewables including hydro are second
but natural gas is still far and away
the largest source of generation that we
have natural gas is used to produce
electricity using a three-step process
first it's extracted from beneath the
earth's surface and delivered to power
plants via pipelines those power plants
use natural gas to power turbines that
allow for the generation of electricity
that electricity is then sent through
power lines for use at your home in 2011
the united states surpassed russia to
become the world's largest producer of
the commodity but extreme weather events
of the last year like the freeze in
texas heat waves in the west and a
hurricane in louisiana have challenged
domestic supply 2041 was a rough year
in terms of disasters that had an effect
on natural gas production so at first
during the texas freeze um a big part of
the problem was a lot of wellheads were
were frozen off and therefore production
dropped pretty precipitously at a time
when demand was very high
hurricane ida didn't help either because
there was a drop-off in production as
oil and gas producers paused production
in the gulf producers in the u.s have
benefited from strong global demand as
they've increased exports to places like
europe there's not a direct correlation
between prices in europe and prices in
the us but they are related in the sense
that for the last several years we have
been exporting natural gas abroad the us
has steadily increased its exports of
liquefied natural gas to europe since
2016. russia is also one of europe's top
suppliers but with the war in ukraine
concerns about natural gas supply are
growing the war in ukraine has made it
so that european countries are trying to
quickly reduce their reliance on russian
gas which creates the need for greater
supplies coming from elsewhere and we
are helping to fill that gap by
exporting more abroad which drives up
prices here by reducing supplies the
confluence of weather events depleting
inventories and higher demand pushing up
prices has led to increased residential
electricity prices across nine regions
on a year-over-year basis in general
when a company's incurring higher energy
costs is able to recoup that through
customers in the form of higher prices
there is some level of regulatory
approval associated with that but it's
usually not disallowed in any way 15
states have seen their home electricity
rates increase by at least 10 from
january of last year but some changes
can help manage the cost a number of
utilities offer plans that
allow you to pay less for electricity if
you're using it outside of peak hours
which is typically maybe four to nine pm
for instance take this mock electric
bill from con edison if the customer
opted for time of use rates they would
see separate charges for on-peak versus
off-peak usage during the summer con
edison's peak rate is approximately 26
cents per kilowatt hour which is around
double the standard rate but during
off-peak hours that customer would only
pay about 2 cents per kilowatt hour peak
rates can vary depending on the utility
so if you want to run your ac or charge
your electric vehicle it may be cheaper
to do so around 9 am or 10 am instead of
in the afternoon when you see a surge in
demand beyond what a consumer can
control a state's public utility
commission can regulate costs but its
reach is limited they do not regulate
natural gas prices but what they can do
is determine the extent to which the
utility can pass through those costs to
consumers in general those costs are
passed through with no change but if you
know for example you had an issue like
the texas freeze in which gas prices
went through the roof the utilities
commission can help determine whether
the utilities should pass through all
those costs or whether it should do so
over a longer period of time so it's not
to hit consumers with huge rate
increases still many believe high
electricity costs may be longer term as
power companies plan to spend the most
money in decades to shift to renewable
energy and replace aging infrastructure
these spending plans have the potential
to further boost rates at a time when
natural gas prices are already fairly
high and other inflationary pressures
have have made you know for example
building renewable energy projects more
expensive for now the increase in
electric bills relate to higher natural
gas prices but if these utilities
receive regulatory approval for their
capital spending plans over the next
several years you may begin to see rate
increases associated with that spending